despite the ease of places like that
drive-through we just mentioned there
are still
many people hesitant to get the covet
vaccine so would a gift card
entice them to do it the health district
is thinking up ways to get a shot in
everybody's arm reporter kate houston
spoke to people
about what it would take i'm not against
vaccinations i just feel like
it was pushed out quickly so they have
side effects kate alcarez is one of many
that are hesitant to get a covid 19
vaccine
after getting the virus in december she
says the possible side effects worry her
especially as she cares
for two young children and i'm like what
am i going to do with my kids
you know if i'm sick for three days so
it's just been that hesitation
of okay i have to prepare myself for
that second shot because i probably will
get sick like everybody else around my
age group
others like nicholas say he's reluctant
because no one in his life had the virus
i think i've been doing pretty good on
taking care of just
washing my hands and making sure i had
my mask going always so
i really never thought i really needed
the vaccine like that
now health officials are working to
reach those on the fence by possibly
including incentives
at this point of the campaign we think
that yes
incentives are very important and we we
will
incorporate that into our campaign
starting tomorrow those who are
vaccinated at the galleria at sunset in
henderson
will be entered into a weekly gift card
drawing for nicholas and alcarez
they're split on whether incentives such
as this would impact their decision
it's not a bad thing you know people be
like oh i was going to do it anyway
might as well get this perk
because a lot of people are like me
they're just they're going to do it it's
just
the whole side effect thing it would
take somebody
that's really close to me to get in to
like really get affected
by it but if i don't like
i really don't see that happening kate
houston 8 news now